it's a great resignation okay the great
resignation there's a story that
everybody is talking about a guy tagged
me in a pic in a post i just send it to
you uh have it ready to bring it up in a
minute here i text it to you so this is
a cnbc story this is the biggest reason
people quit and it's 10 times more
important than pay
from the data class to review from the
last few years including before the
pandemic and 172 culture metrics at
roughly 600 companies researchers found
toxic war culture to be the biggest
factor that led people to quit and ten
times more important than pay in
predicting turnover okay so toxic
culture is number one is what they're
saying this is cnbc story the most
common ways employees describe toxic
culture at their company were through a
failure to promote diversity equity
inclusion workers feeling disrespected
unethical behavior or low integrity
abusive managers and a cutthroat
environment where they felt colleagues
were actively undermining so they're
describing cnn okay so what's
significant is that toxic workplace
factors lead to a stronger reaction
quitting
more so than other bad work issues
people may grumble about their workplace
being bureaucratic or feeling sl uh
siloed but they still don't leave but
signs of toxic war culture are making
people walk away so uh tyler just out of
curiosity is that the only story you
have on the great resignation or is
there anything else on great resignation
that you have uh on there that's it but
we can
pull a few things out it's been the top
story on linkedin it's like there's a
million stores so this one guy sends me
this and he says you never talk about
this on the podcast i said okay let's
talk about it so corporations right now
laid off staff in 2020 okay
uh received generous government bailouts
totally agree a lot of people took the
bailouts shouldn't have taken they did
not need it a lot of companies didn't
need that bailout we had a board meeting
and our board meeting i brought this up
before they said you know we can get
roughly four and a half million dollars
i said we're not taking the money
because we don't need the restaurants
needed i'm not taking that 4.5 million
good for you but guess what you don't
have to pay it back i said i'm not
taking a penny my board was upset with
me saying every single one of the boards
we sit on they take the money you ain't
taking the money i'm not taking the
money why would i take the money how
hypocritical are my philosophies to take
that money and put under the bank
account but you know what you're going
to pay for through taxes that makes you
think you better take it because you're
going to pay through tax that's my
philosophy i totally get it you're going
to pay through tax i'm like you know
what i'm good the restaurant needs it
those 50 million employees in america
that are directly or indirectly affected
by those restaurants that have to shut
down let's kind of help those guys that
i'm gonna be okay
using myths of resignation and labor
shortage to understaff okay i i have no
idea what you mean by that but okay uh
this is a liberal facebook fan page just
so you know so i'm showing what they put
shovel work on people that don't have a
better option okay that's absolutely
ludicrous let me explain to you why
people have more options today than ever
before i'm going to show you something
from an economist i heard last week in
vegas that is going to blow you away and
it's not going to be a good look for a
certain president and it's not who you
think it is when i go through it shovel
work on people you know what the
challenge is today the challenge today
is here's how it works okay
you hire somebody
you give them 45 000
they've never made forty five thousand
dollars you hire somebody again fifty
five thousand dollars
but they have a now new title so they go
on lincoln and they change the title to
such and such title the recruiting firm
calls them saying hey you're xyz at this
company yes we'll offer you seventy
thousand dollars with this other company
and they'll give you five thousand
dollar bonus the guy has one month of
experience in that job so guess what he
says he comes back to the box that gave
him the job and he says hey uh i love
this place but let me just tell you what
offer i just got if you give me the
seventy thousand dollars and a five
thousand dollar bonus we can we can keep
you here
that boss is staying there and saying
what the
what do you want me to do
i need this guy but you're not worth
this dollar amount so then he sits there
and he says
dude i can't afford to pay you man that
kind of money but maybe we can bump you
to 60. let me see what i can do i'm
sorry i got to take this job he takes
that job at seventy thousand with the
five thousand dollar signing bonus a
month later the same recruiter calls him
calls another company says this other
company wants to pay you eighty two
thousand dollars with a seven thousand
dollar bonus this guy is under qualified
he says hey man you know i'm you know
i'm so sorry bro but you know i love
this place but you know to do we can't
be dude you ain't worried
no i'm doing seven thousand one
i gotta go take the he takes that job do
you know i know a guy that went through
the cycle four times by the same
recruiter getting until he got to six
figures because the company was willing
to pay for it so that fourth one right
there is a is a bunch of uh gibberish
yeah but you can't blame that guy for
taking the money this is free agent no
no no no no wait a minute no hear me out
in nba i get how many guys get overpaid
because they had a big breakout season
or they did well in the playoffs and
next thing you know they were a two
million dollar guy now they're getting a
you know 50 million dollar five-year
contract what are you going to say well
i'm not really
i'm not sure you're going to take the
money i'm not sitting here and telling
you anything first of all that guy's not
a loyalty guy his loyalty is to money go
get your money do whatever people are
that's that's not true but fine no
problem i i say that company their comp
structure needs a better adjustment
meaning
if you want to get people to stick
around with you maybe give them equity
maybe give them long-term incentives
that they can participate in maybe you
got to make certain adjustments there i
don't disagree there but all i'm telling
you is people are you you say most
people are driven by money okay so let
me ask you a question i'm not saying
most people are here for money but i'm
saying most people but wait can i say
this thing yes
and all of a sudden someone's giving you
a hundred and you're actually thinking
they're gonna maybe maybe not they're
taking the hundreds really but but do
you realize what you're setting as your
reputation on your resume let me explain
to you so so you're thinking about
getting married one day no yes okay are
you the richest guy in the world
no that's elon musk
so that means every girl should leave
their husbands and go with a llama so
let's just say you get married to your
wife let's just say you're married to
your girl drop that gorgeous girl you're
gonna marry hot girl we know that but
let's just marry your girl i appreciate
it but you ain't the richest guy in
miami you're definitely in the richest
june miami
so now she needs another jew okay who's
worth 100 million and he says wink wink
you come with me i'll get you an s 500
and i'll get you this house if you leave
me so now hey you should take your money
and go to the next guy and then she gets
another guy is that the like the way
well the difference is you can only
marry one person at the time
but the point is that's your mormon that
is not a good look on your resume to
show you have four jobs like when people
i agree with you on that you can't just
go from job to job to job the job but
that's what if you keep getting more
bonuses that to me that to me is also a
mindset that you can be bought you're
for sale it is not a good values and
principles on the individual
you create a market and say i come and i
make you work here then you force that
company to pay you exactly what you're
worth in the marketplace because there
have to there is no choice when i give
you a promotion to coo i have to pay you
what the market is for this year if i
give you a promotion to a any promoter i
have to pay you what the market tells me
you go on salary.com and salary.com says
what
the position
for a director of digital media in fort
lauderdale is the low 78 000 high 150
medium 100 whatever it's going to tell
me oh i got dude so what do we got
am i going to get this or not i have to
work it because you're in favor if you
deliver that guy who changes position
four times the company is eventually
going to realize this guy's clueless and
he's going to get fired four months
later so then he has to go back and
explain to somebody else why he got
fired he's got to make an excuse well
you know it was because of equity and
because it's a toxic toxic environment
and it was just a terrible place seth i
got to tell you pat i've been in places
where that guy is terrible and doesn't
get fired specifically because he got
hired and that's worse for the company
because that company doesn't have
leadership and they're desperate let me
do the last one and i'll open it up i
want to hear you guys thoughts use the
myth of inflation to raise prices folks
that's not myth the myth that's called
math do me a favor go to one of the
slides that this chief economist jd
go up five slides uh uh uh and by the
way keep going up keep going up keep
going up i think that's the one no not
that one go one more yeah that one right
there okay can you make that bigger so
everybody can see that and david can you
put that on the screen so everyone can
see it are we going back to that last
slide by the way because the guy only
got the one top thing right or the
second thing and then the last three
were just absolute garbage yeah but but
but if the media keeps saying toxic
toxic toxic toxic toxic here's what's
going on the company's inflation pop-up
they're just bullshitting using
inflation to raise prices here's what's
going on with energy inflation make it a
little bit bigger so they can see that
can you make that even bigger go bigger
bigger bigger so people can see the
years on the bottom okay so that shows
what energy inflation happened this year
look at that spike the last time it's
been this high was jimmy carter era
that's not a joke energy inflation it's
only 70 yeah it's only seven percent
yeah okay no no it's not seven percent
it's not seven percent oh yeah i see
what you're saying yeah yeah i i i miss
the satire i buy groceries fake news i'm
fake news guys
let me catch up to you guys i'm a little
bit behind i'll catch up give me a
couple minutes automobile inflation look
at that highest and how many years like
even carter was 28
dude that's 35 percent dude what are you
talking about
who's saying that it's a myth though
nobody in their right mind i believe
that inflation is a myth right now jen
sackey said
that these companies are using inflation
to raise prices and that's
greedy they're being greedy right she i
went to starbucks the other day i tell
jen bae place an order for me for
whatever this thing that you order from
me i don't even know what it's called
she knows what it's called so
a fog something i don't know what
it's called anyways it's sick so i get
this tea and she says babe i called
everywhere all the starbucks that i go
over when i come back from the gym with
e
she says uh they don't have the product
what are you talking about so i go there
so i look at the girl at the cashier i
said hey can i get this one we don't
have that can i get this one we don't
have that
what do you have so she says honestly i
said just put something in let me go
talk to the girl at the front i go to
the front the guy's a die hard podcast
fan die hard like the entire time he
will let me go because he followed the
podcast he says uh pat
we don't have 80 of our products to sell
i said what do you say we don't have
syrup we don't have this i can't sell
you this thing i said just make me
whatever he says let me see what i can
do guy goes to the back to make me
something that's not on the what do you
call it on the menu and he comes back oh
yeah they're raising prices
there's shortage of products if only
there was like six stuff a hundred years
of of evidence of central planning
failing yeah like if only anyways i mean
the point is the point is that this
article by cnbc the average person reads
this article what do they say you know
here's here's how it goes okay you know
the guy that flirts with the 18 year old
girl who doesn't have game and the guy's
29 years old experience and he sees his
18 year old girl that's dating a guy
that they're together or like 20 year
old girl and he says let me ask you a
question
does your boyfriend all he care about is
working out doesn't he
yeah
he spends more time at the gym than you
let me guess he's that good-looking guy
that only watches his car and plays
video games and hangs out at his boys
and he doesn't give you the attention
you deserve
yeah
if you were my girl
from morning till night you'd be my
focus
i'd give all my attention to you and i
think you need to be treated that way
dude i'm a little i'm a little
uncomfortable
the point is you write something like
this someone's gonna say my job doesn't
promote diversity doesn't promote equity
doesn't promote it is it is it's a
resentment yeah it's all resentment so
uh you know
when when people
say that their workplace is toxic and
they're listing these reasons i'm
thinking to myself you know what they're
saying is oh my boss makes more than me
this is a toxic environment
like you know uh there's not enough
there's not equity equity is like
is like having the same outcome
you know if you're if you're expecting
in the workplace that someone who works
harder than you is should have the same
outcome as you otherwise it's toxic then
you don't understand the workplace you
don't understand a meritocracy
right i mean and it's all it all comes
down to envy and resentment it comes
down to
wanting what other people have what
other people are willing to work for
that you're not willing to work for
and otherwise and if you don't have it
then you feel abused i mean it's like
this childish immature uh resentful
attitude that people are bringing into
the workplace when i when i heard toxic
i was thinking something very different
i was thinking it would be something
where there's like it's like this bros
world where the guys are like you know
the patriarchy is in charge and there's
like sexual harassment and all this like
uber yeah i wasn't thinking diversity
like the wolf of wall street exactly
wolf of wall street you know all that
kind of stuff but i wasn't thinking
diversity and equity and and and all of
that
hard to tell who the two business owners
on the panel are but the uh look i've
been in toxic workplace environments and
i think what pat said before is really
really interesting because
it's the amount of options that you have
and you made a correlation between this
and relationships it's the same thing
like before tinder before bumble you had
incentive to work things out with your
girl and then maybe you get through that
you get through your early hurdles in
the relationship and then it turns into
a long-term thing but now it's just like
screw this swipe right swipe right swipe
right find somebody new it's the same
thing you know i
i told you about uh the encounter i had
with the overzealous sales manager you
know where i almost caught a felony
that's the toxic workplace environment
now at the time uber didn't exist lyft
didn't exist you know now they do you
know what i and during the pandemic i
went from two national tours getting
canceled to having to do construction
and lift and you know what it wasn't bad
man you could make like you can make 40
50 grand a year if you do live full time
you're just sitting in your own car
you're listening to music you're you
have nobody to answer to now you have
the liability in a way you're an
entrepreneur in that way you're taking
it upon yourself so i i am all for
employees
bettering themselves bettering their
using their opportunities to leverage
themselves into a life that they deserve
and i think at the end of the day this
will be a good thing for businesses to
adjust
but it's just like anything else you got
to compete for labor in the marketplace
right you have to compete so that guy in
in your the guy who was paying the dude
40 000 the person at the end of that
line who pays 100 000 is probably a
but the guy who's playing forty
thousand needs to adjust his business
model as well right if he wants that
same like we think about this like you
buy this at costco it's 50 cents so we
have a valuation and this bottle of
water is only 50 cents but you go to the
airport and it's four dollars now the
person that's been paying 50 cents for
this their whole life is like who's the
that's paying four dollars you see
three people go up and buy it you're
worth what somebody's gonna pay you
that's what you're worth right so i mean
are you
actually worth that well that's for
people like you to ascertain like what
is what is my stress level on talent
right what is my stress level on on
employment and then the other side of it
becomes you push too hard like the
unions have done forever and it's like
okay well now you're forcing us to find
another way
to do your job because you're too
expensive and income the machines or the
outgo outsourcing things like that so i
mean i just think we're in a very
disruptive time right now where
i don't there's people that again you
know i don't want to go on all these
long rants but it's like nobody you talk
to kids under 25 years old not a single
one of them thinks about the buying a
house and the white picket fence and
like they just think that they're going
to live paycheck to paycheck their whole
life so i'll if i'm not enjoying what
i'm doing i'll bail and i'll find
something else so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you